hey Vsauce how's it going Michael here
and today I'm trying out a new type of
show basically I just want to collect
all the awesome images that I've seen
this week into one place last week was a
source of a bunch of fantastic images so
without further ado welcome to Episode
one of IMG
if not even floodwaters can get between
you and video games you're gonna love
the newest screenshots that were
released for the upcoming Battletoads 3d
I'm sorry that pictures like five years
old but let's move on to stuff that was
popular this week first stop Kotaku
besides Chris Brown wearing kirby
bowling we also got the best use of
pixelation ever it's a hot girl blurred
out with pixelation to look like
Princess Peach as a great follow up
here's the equivalent of a visual cold
shower terrifying pokemon from eat toast
but now it's time for a challenge named
every character in this illustration of
the Marvel Universe in the style of
Megaman it's called of course mega
marvelous yesterday this picture was
circulating a lot rumor had it that it
was taken at a Justin Bieber concert but
what bothers me is how sad this kid
looks but if it doesn't make you sad
maybe this will last week man eggs calm
asked what if Mario faced real
consequences
of course the only person worse off that
Mario is a person who owns cats last
week cat versus human reminded me why I
need to get a girlfriend or at least
talk to someone besides my kitties
because cats during emergencies not a
good idea The Huffington Post assembled
a great list of fictional characters
caught in real life my favorites Mario
and Luigi Carmen Sandiego and that puffy
kid from up Earl s scoured Flickr for
the best midair poses and BuzzFeed
brought us the 15 gayest pictures of the
Pope they also brought us incredible
reimagining of popular current games as
8-bit and 16-bit games and what the heck
a guy who carves tiny teeny-weeny
sculptures out of pencil leg finally
today the Chive posted a hilarious
series of pictures an employee
supposedly emailed to her entire office
in what has to be the most creative
clever and simultaneously sexy way to
quit enjoy
okay that's it for the first episode of
IMG but there's way more to come in fact
I would really love input from you guys
so feel free to submit your favorite
images of the week to our Facebook page
over at facebook.com/vsaucetwo mean and
as far as I'm concerned the more gifts
the better